une poignée de main cordiales entre Maya
sandou et Ursula Vander la hyène
Akishino la présidente moldave souhaite
la bienvenue à la dirigeante européenne
pour elle ce sommet de la communauté
politique européenne constitue une
opportunité de se rapprocher de lieu
la Moldavie a beaucoup d'amis proches
qui nous soutiennent dans notre
aspiration de construire une Moldavie
européenne
la présence de ces leaders dans notre
pays
et votre présence cherrure Soula envoie
le message très clair que la Moldavie
n'est pas seule
je dis les 27 États membres de l'UE
ainsi que 20 autres pays européens sont
invités en Moldavie un événement rare
pour ce pays de 2 millions 600 000
habitants depuis l'invasion russe de
l'Ukraine voisine les autorités
s'inquiètent de l'ingérence de Moscou
dans leurs affaires une menace qui
renforce le sentiment pro-européen de
nombreux moldavres comme en témoigne
cette manifestation il y a dix jours
pour réclamer une adhésion rapide à
l'Union européenne
depuis juin dernier la Moldavie est
officiellement candidate avec une
perspective d'intégration à l'horizon
2030 un objectif réalisable selon ours
ou la vendeur lion
à propos des réformes de la Moldavie
pour progresser sur le chemin de l'Union
européenne je vois clairement que vous
faites de gros progrès
ce jeudi le sommet débute dans ce
domaine viticole de l'Est de la Moldavie
l'occasion pour les dirigeants européens
d'envoyer un message d'unité à Moscou à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de la
frontière ukrainienne